this is star talk neil degrasse tyson
here your personal astrophysicist and
this is going to be a cosmic queries
edition
on the subject of mending the ozone
layer chuck my co-host always good to
have you here chad always a pleasure
very excited for this yeah you know that
the ozone layer got mended that's a
thing yeah it's like you think a pair of
it's like oh i have a hole in the toe of
my planet
how do i sew that up
it got men it got darned
so uh my two guests uh susan solomon and
stephen anderson chuck have you ever
heard of them
as a matter of fact i have oh because
you're a learned man most people haven't
and what's weird is to have not heard of
someone who actually
saved the world exactly this is just a
weird
fact that such a thing could even exist
i'm in the process of working on two
marvel characters
and patterning them
after after these two
[Laughter]
susan and stephen
let's get
wearing the capes and capes and
everything neil
capes and all capes and everything well
let me let's take that moment to
introduce susan solomon welcome to star
talk stephen anderson welcome welcome
and if you give me a moment to give some
of your background here you you each
receive the future of life award
that's even a thing that's a thing for
your contributions to mending the hole
in the ozone layer and it's given this
award i'm so glad this award exists
because you know it's
it's given to unsung heroes
people who
were under recognized
relative to what they actually
accomplished in in in improving the
world
and so and they and by the way they also
participated in the nobel prize for
peace
um when it was given to the
international panel on climate change
the ipcc in 2007 uh for their
contributions to those reports so
they're you know
unlike most of us they're trying to make
the world a better place right
and so let's go back in time briefly to
1989 something called the montreal
protocol an international treaty you
know before there was the paris
you know the
talks and the treaties that went on
there we had the montreal
protocol back in 1989 and that was
trying to protect the ozone layer
by phasing out the production
of
of of molecules substances known to
deplete it
and sometimes people refer to it as the
most successful treaty of our day and
susan you're an atmospheric chemist
i love it
and yeah and you're a professor of
environmental studies at mit in in an
endowed chair the lee and geraldine
martin professor of environmental
studies
up in cambridge and so and you spent
most of your career with the national
oceanic and atmospheric administration
and chuck you know i love it because
um
the national oceanic and asthma
atmospheric administration they were
they concerned themselves with the ocean
and the atmosphere right yeah and
but if you pronounce the acronym it's
noah
that was cool
which is kind of cool
i guess noah himself didn't need noah
because he had god telling him look it's
going to rain at four exactly
noah don't don't listen to those people
mocking you
and we have stephen anderson here
director of research american director
of research um for the institute for
governance and sustainable development
man you guys are doing such good stuff
yeah what am i doing here with this
podcast i want to hire me
and your co-chair of the montreal
protocol for technology and economic
assessment panel so this is how people
put they contribute via all of these
panels and you also we're a liaison to
the department of defense from the
environmental protection agency so you
are the right people for this for this
formulation here so and neil now now
that we have the uh requisite uh
introductions out of the way and and the
credentials actually is
i just have to do this for both of these
uh fine fine scientists
[Applause]
that is applause my friend oh that's a
watercolor that's a great deal of
applause a rousing applause is what that
is
thank you
all right so let me ask you guys um so
susan let me start with you
how does this happen i mean somebody has
to first discover
that there's an ozone layer that it has
value to us
that is getting depleted that we are
responsible for it and then we have to
do something about it then create a
committee and then a a a
an international gathering and then
everybody has to agree to it and then
actually implement it what this is that
who
whoever thought that was possible in
this world it seems kind of like a
miracle doesn't it i mean it is it is
just amazing that it happened and neil i
want to tell you you are so perfect i
mean you're great but actually the
montreal protocol was signed in 1987 not
1989. so
no biggie no biggie
but
okay well that's uh that's 24 months of
failure
[Laughter]
so
a long story short i guess in
1974 two scientists who later won the
nobel prize for chemistry uh molina and
roland they won it together with paul
kreutzen
but molina and roland's big contribution
was to alert the world to the idea that
the chlorofluorocarbons might someday
deplete the ozone layer now we thought
this was going to be a small effect
a couple of percent a hundred years in
the future
sound kind of like another problem the
way some people
yeah don't get us started on that you
should talk about it used to talk about
it but uh
the uh interesting thing is that uh
although they had certain things
correct they did not anticipate that
things could be even worse than they
thought so it turned out just quickly
susan you said
chlorofluorocarbons that sounds like a
word with one or two too many syllables
so tell me what tell us what the
chlorofluorocarbon is
uh well you can uh picture uh a methane
molecule i guess most people have heard
of methane
uh swamp gas or what you put in your in
your uh you know natural gas system
maybe and i have to explain it to chuck
chuck it's what you tried to ignite at
camp absolutely right that's it that's
it
so take take that molecule
and just tear off all the hydrogens and
put in fluorine and chlorine instead and
you've got a chlorofluorocarbon
and the most important ones are
chlorofluorocarbon
11 and 12 which i'm not going to give
you the chemical formulas for but most
of the chlorine that's causing the
problem is in that form uh and then
there's a whole zoo of other compounds
113 114 150 and where did it come from
where does it come from so we were using
these molecules in ever increasing
amounts
and ironically uh the main source was
actually in
your medicine cabinet
in things like hairspray and deodorant
but it was also you know oven cleaner
and paint and anything else that you
sprayed out of a can uh had
chlorofluorocarbons in them to make the
stuff come out the nozzle it was a
propellant in the can oh okay it's it's
used for other things too it's used as
the cooling agent in refrigerators
it's uh it was used i should say um and
it was used in foams so you know foam
insulation in the walls of homes that
were built in you know like the 60s and
70s
but
we don't use any chlorofluorocarbon in
those applications anymore and yet we
still have spray cans we still have
refrigerators we still have air
conditioners
i mean
it didn't didn't collapse technology is
amazing you know you can actually do
things lots of different ways which is
that which is what steve's group helped
helped us to uh to show
so uh you know we were gaily spraying
our our hair you remember those horrible
hairstyles of the 70s you know people so
big hair big hair beehives beehives
remember the beehives they were great
so um
then these guys said hey if we keep
doing this we might deplete the ozone
layer and the amazing thing is
that people actually said oh well
what can we do about it and the answer
was well
you know one thing you could do is throw
away your spray deodorant and get the
roll-on instead
and a lot of people said oh well that's
not really very hard is it so a lot of
people did it in this country not in a
lot of other countries actually it
wasn't so in europe
which was the other major producer wait
a minute wait a minute
they use deodorant in europe
i don't know susan
you might you might want to check your
sources
just remind you he's a comedian
wait so stephen stephen let me ask you
how do you how do you tell people to get
rid of what they have if in that moment
you don't have something to replace it
with that's exactly the question and i
would just add to what susan said uh
before we move on that one of the
stimulants for action was the scientists
uh sherwood rowland and mario molina
uh after six months of relative silence
after the publication of their warning
uh went to the american chemical society
and called for a boycott
by citizens of hairspray and deodorant
so these are scientists that are active
as scientists they were right out there
and then the industry
fortunately in a strange way reacted so
strongly
against them that it sensationalized the
news
and it spread across the world and susan
mentioned some nordic countries united
states and canada banned these products
and then to get to your question
even as the boycott began there were
companies
that broke from industry and introduced
the alternatives and so there were pumps
and sprays and
roll-ons and
lots of alternatives and then very
quickly they found a new
aerosol propellant
that was not ozone depleting and they
introduced that so you had this creative
tension within the industry within the
aerosol industry where some of the
companies st johnson and mennon and
others were in favor of protecting the
ozone layer and they won against their
competition penetrated the market
uh the products were banned and as as
susan mentioned you hardly noticed
that these product changes were
occurring
and then later with the montreal
protocol it was a much more organized
process the part that i worked on
with the montreal protocol was to
evaluate technology promote the best of
the technology
and then very importantly to discourage
the alternatives that were inferior in
one way or the other so they were very
successful at not trading one problem
for another and actually making the
overall improvement very quickly so this
there's a lesson here that if you want
to make systemic change
domestically or internationally you
gotta it's for it to work
swiftly and effectively it's gotta
you've gotta sort of energize all
parts of that beast or that machine
that is
that ultimately is the force of change
in this world yeah money yeah you're
okay there you go i'm sorry that's the
word i'm sorry i i i listen you know i
understand i have three scientists in
front of me you know but i can say it
money right that's what happened we had
the free market you had some pressure by
science you had a portion of the portion
of the marketplace say hey i'm going to
respond that creates competition then
before you know it it's like hey i don't
want to lose any of this money forget
i'm spraying money away
so susan were there you're right you're
right chuck but you left out something
really important and that is people the
fact that people really cared about this
issue they actually understood and could
perceive that
the idea of having more more ultraviolet
light falling on them if there was less
ozone
everybody knows the ozone layer protects
us from ultraviolet light from the sun
and we don't want to get we get
sunburned
it hurts it's bad for us we get skin
cancer we get cataracts the plants get
sick you know lots of bad things people
cared about it because they could see
what was going on so don't forget the
the the importance of public interest
it's huge in any environmental problem
otherwise you're arguing in a void and
even if you're right it wouldn't it
would be difficult if not impossible to
gain traction that's right
yeah that makes me worry about future
problems that don't have ways to get
traction yet they still need to be
implemented for the survival of the
species now you got me all worried no
don't worry don't worry have you seen
greta tunberg going out oh
yeah happening it is definitely
happening the young people today are
incredibly environmentally conscious
that's true i can't wait till they take
over because the world we messed up i
mean
at what time in the history of the
universe has the adult population ever
said can't wait till the youngins take
over to fix things
that's never happened ever and this we
might be living
in that for the very first time we got
to take a break but when we come back
we'll take questions from our fan base
from our patreon fan base on because
they all know we have a scientifically
literate audience and so i think they'll
be delighted to know they have access to
the two of you and chuck you've collated
the questions so when we when we come
back cosmic queries mending the ozone
layer when we return
we're back star talk cosmic queries
mending the ozone layer somebody had to
do it yeah so we got two people in the
house in the virtual zoom house who
were
uh
under celebrated for what it is they
achieved and it's time more people
knew their names i've got susan solomon
an atmospheric chemist and stephen
anderson who
has
spent a career
worrying and thinking about
sort of
how to create sustainable civilization
and what you need to do
about that and making it something real
rather than just something we've all
imagined and so uh here we are we've we
solicited questions from our fan base
about mending the ozone layer so chuck
what do you have
yes
yes we did you know well
before we go can i just ask
just so that people can know
because we do susan said it you know
everybody knows about ultraviolet light
and the ozone protects us from that so
can you guys just i mean all three of
you or any of you give us
how does that happen
why does that happen this might be the
only thing i can contribute to this
podcast go for it now can i can i take
my stab at this okay absolutely okay so
the uh 21 of the air we breathe is
oxygen
and most of it is not oxygen it's
nitrogen and so that oxygen itself is in
a form of two oxygen atoms combined and
we call it o2
o2 that's what we breathe that's what
sustains us the nitrogen is is just
filler basically relative to our um
survival it's filler it's the bread in
our crab cake
okay
that's probably the
that'd be too much bread for my crab
right exactly but okay so there's a form
of oxygen
that it has three oxygen atoms it's o3
and that's called ozone
and
ozone has the property
which is if it if you have ultraviolet
light that strikes that molecule
that's sufficient energy to break the
molecule apart
back into oxygen and an o2
and so
so what so you say what happened to the
uv it's gone
it goes into the kinetic energy of those
two
uh
of the two resulting particles and so
it's gone
so the ultraviolet from the sun
so i get the right number from our two
guests
97 98 99 of the uv from the sun does not
reach earth's surface because of the
ozone so even when you do get sunburned
that's from the little bit that gets
through after the ozone is trying to do
its best and so if you take out the
ozone layer that's the end of life on
earth as we know it life on earth's
surface because ultraviolet light and
biology
are
are incommensurate
ultraviolet has enough energy to break
apart biological molecules how did i do
steven and susan you did great you did
great i mean at the very end you said
the key thing which is that the uv light
hitting your skin or hitting your eyes
is enough to actually damage your dna
and that's what causes you know cancer
so so um
the only other thing that i i would add
is that every one percent change in the
ozone layer is estimated to cause a two
to three percent increase in skin cancer
in light-skinned people
so it's not as much of a problem in dark
people but it's not zero problem either
and everybody's got
the same problem with their eyes it
doesn't matter whether they're blue or
or brown or black
your eyes will will still be subject to
cataracts because the light gets through
and damages your retina so it's not good
news and it's it's indiscriminate to you
know
whether you put the stuff up there or
not so it's happening all around the
world we've got about
i got to whisper something to chuck
finally okay wait chuck chuck
so it all got solved so quickly because
it affected white people right well yes
and i was going to say
don't tell anybody but i was going to
say finally finally
one good thing about being a black man
finally
don't be too sanguine chuck i don't want
you to get cataracts and you still can
get melanoma which is not good
i wear sunblock every day but not
because i'm worried about uv uh rays
it's just because i want to
look good you want to glow yeah
that was great that was great all right
this is samuel case who says hello big
brains and
[Laughter]
what can i do right it goes i love you
all and thank you for your gift of
knowledge i run a small ac company in
phoenix arizona and i have been directly
affected by legislation regarding
climate change in particular the 2014
phasing out of hcfc r22 i was wondering
if you could explain the actual effects
of chlorine or refrigerant on the
atmosphere itself thank you and for
giving me this small opportunity uh to
play a part in the exploration of our
planet cool and tell me tell me the
person's name again this is samuel case
samuel case very cool so so i guess the
question is what is actually going on up
there there's the ozone mining its own
business the o3 molecule and now this
jumbo
chlorofluorocarbon molecule
meets it
so now take us through that
yeah let me let me go through that
because this air conditioning case is
very interesting he's absolutely right
that hcfc 22 depletes the ozone and it's
also a greenhouse gas powerful
greenhouse gas so here we have
a refrigerant that was once used in
every air conditioner of small size
everywhere in the world and then under
the montreal protocol
they they're phasing out that chemical
the last uses are occurring in
developing countries and for servicing
of old air conditioning that hasn't been
replaced
so the
chlorine in this chemical
as susan mentioned migrates to the
stratosphere destroys the ozone and
harms
people through these biological and
other effects and far it also harms as
you know materials on the surface of
built environment it also suppresses the
human immune system
so this is an extraordinary
environmental effect that in itself uh
justified the montreal protocol but the
greenhouse effect
from the refrigerant itself which is the
direct effect of
of that gas entering the high atmosphere
and
and the like was also serious and then
the third leg of that is the energy
that's used for the air conditioner
itself
because until recently that came from
coal and oil and other polluting sources
and so this change that's occurring in
arizona at this air conditioning company
has a broad advantage to society because
the new refrigerants are safe for the
ozone layer they're lower in their
direct effect on the climate and the
equipment itself is more efficient than
the equipment that was sold historically
so it's a change for the company and
it's a heroic effort for an individual
company to change the tools and the
tanks and retrain the workers but it's
for the good of society and we're just
getting through that change
from the montreal protocol and now we're
entering a new stage where the
refrigerant he's using now which is
called
hfc
410a
which is a blend of two of these
chemicals that are ozone same
is still a greenhouse gas so we're
making a change to a lower g a lower gwp
uh less damaging refrigerant and we're
increasing the energy efficiency again
so this is a case of continuous
improvement and
innovation and the strength of the
montreal protocol that it just keeps
giving the signal that you talked about
neil and you talked about chuck that
there's the
profit motive and then there's also a
tremendous amount of
of the of the altruistic motive of
companies that want to do better for
earth and their employees and their
customers and yeah plus they can they
get to advertise that that they're right
that they're all that they're
environmentally uh preferred chemicals
so that's right yeah
i love that and you guys in arizona
which last we checked
sits a quarter mile from the surface of
the sun yes
in the summertime
almost earth's orbit swings just arizona
real close
well there you go uh samuel case you too
can be your hero man make the transition
yeah good very good awesome
that was great okay jeff johnson wants
to know this are we at the point of no
return leaving the ozone and going
straight to uh climate change here uh
are we at the point of no return with
runaway
climate change
are there any potential technologies
that can reverse the effects
yes susan let me get you to respond to
that because you uh
if you're an atmospheric chemist
you you would be plugged into
not only the causes and effects of our
atmospheric transgressions but also what
could possibly be remedies to it
beyond just okay stop what you're doing
all right is there some other sort of
chemical geoengineering solution
to what's going on here
well
people have talked about geoengineering
the planet i mean personally
i'm just not a fan of experimenting with
systems that you don't understand very
well
so really yeah
really you know yeah i you know i i i
don't volunteer for medical trials i
mean it just depends on how you feel
about risk but you know the problem is
that um we can't you know we can't make
a decision for the whole world just
because some people want to go out there
and go skydiving right i mean some
people really don't don't have the same
values about risk that i do so your
feelings about geo engineering i think
have a lot to do with how you
how you are as far as risk averse or not
and i i'm actually honestly pretty
risk-averse
i can tell you that on mars where there
is no ozone layer
these
as far as we've been able to measure the
surface of mars is sterile
because the uv light comes straight on
down and if we're ever going to
terraform mars we're going to need some
uv shielding
and we're thinking ozone of course but
um
so
whatever it is the risks you want or
don't want to take are things somebody's
gonna have to think about if we're gonna
be a two planet species
that's true but at the moment we don't
really have a lot of species on mars as
far as we know we're doing okay so
you know not not quite the same level of
you know risk to life up there as well
all life forms on mars right now are
robotic
it is the robotic planet of
the galaxy i guess aren't people still
looking for like little tiny
cyanobacteria or something i mean you
know microbes not on the surface but
there might be underground aquifers that
would be shielded from the uv and so
there's some attempt to
think about it but but you know
when you absolutely but when you come to
the earth and you talk about
geoengineering you got to say okay well
maybe it's going to change rainfall gee
you know
uh the people who are already suffering
from drought in say australia you know
they might not like that too much you
know right um
so chuck can i answer that a little bit
so i would agree with the caller that
we're at the point of no return
and it's pretty desperate if you look at
the ipcc report or if you look at the
wild power buyers in california yeah
we're close to the end of the time where
we could make easy choices
so right now there's tremendous
opportunity to phase down these hfcs i
mentioned that are controlled now under
the montreal protocol a big part of the
of the new opportunity is to
uh phase down methane get rid of run of
the leaks of methane and cut back on the
exploitation and these gases have a
short-term powerful effect on the
climate so if you if you take out those
chemicals quickly then you won't find
yourself as desperate as to require the
kind of experimental geoengineering that
you're going to talk about that's an
important fact here the rate at which
things change yes yeah yeah yeah but but
still you know we i guess uh the
question was about the runaway
greenhouse effect idea and uh i i think
that's conceivable but honestly there
isn't too much evidence that we're close
to that point right now and one one
that's a different kind of irreversible
effect right yeah that's venus
genus
that's venus and you know uh that that
could happen if we kept going full bore
petal to the metal but i just don't
think that's going to happen given the
kind of climate changes that we're
seeing today
but it's safe to say that um
putting the runaway effect aside
that
climate change itself is kind of like a
snowball rolling downhill or a mack
truck on a on a gradient that a a
decline and that as it picks up speed
it's much harder to slow down and then
once you hit the brakes it's still going
to keep going forward no matter what
you know that's a misconception a lot of
people have chuck okay good um yeah um
uh
let's see where do i start with this i
guess what i'll say is the thing that is
rolling downhill fast is actually the
development of
the commitments that we human beings
have to infrastructure that uses fossil
fuels which are the source of our co2 so
the problem and and to me it's uh you
know it's it's hard to talk about it as
a problem i i fervently believe that
people in the developing world have
every right to develop you know it is
fundamental to their health their you
know their their future their education
of their kids i mean you name it it's
fundamental to life to to to go for for
a developing world to continue to
develop and in order to develop
if they develop using fossil fuels as
they get richer as is now happening in
our globalized society
then more and more power plants we built
and more and more cars will be bought
and the question is are those going to
be fossil fuel powered cars and fossil
fuel powered you know coal powered uh
power plants or are they going to be
clean energy systems that means you see
the writing on the wall based on what
the future institutional
uh societal commitments are going to be
in the coming decades and that doesn't
look good to you right now
let me check here that
the runaway the runaway is that the
momentum of technology has to be turned
back very quickly because you can't turn
it over quick if you look at what you
own your house your appliances your cars
the vacations you plan all your property
this takes a long time to turn this over
so you've got to get an early start and
the part of the runaway i'm worried
about is things like the melting arctic
and sea level rise and and liberating
the methane from the tundra and so forth
and those are real concerns that if you
go too far with that it'll be a long
time coming back and susan's published
this and on the long life of carbon
dioxide these are extraordinary
difficult changes to make the sooner you
change the better and i think we're
behind schedule on these kinds of
commitments people should be making okay
so what you're saying is we're all going
to die we're all going to that's what
you're saying
i can't believe i just laughed at that i
know right right oh that's what we do in
our field all the time
but i just want to say one thing it's
great to roll back methane and
hydrofluorocarbons and all the rest of
it but let's not forget carbon dioxide
is job one it's really our fossil fuel
economy that that is our problem and and
you know uh if it distracts us
from working on reducing fossil fuel use
to work on methane we we should
definitely not do that i think we've got
good news
they're different people there's
absolutely no overlap that you can do
two things at once right hand left hand
industry's got to get moving on all this
stuff at the same time or all these jobs
will end up as job one or john job last
so
i would urge i would urge all the
readers and the listeners of this to
investigate themselves but yeah we've
got to get going here well we've got
another we're going to take another
break before our third and final segment
chuck i think we only got to like two
questions i know okay we're gonna have
to go like lightning we're gonna go
quickly okay we'll do lightning round in
the third segment when we come back
cosmic queries mending the ozone layer
we're back cosmic queries mending the
ozone layer with chuck knight chuck
your social media chuck nice comic yes
everywhere thank you everywhere good
good good and we got with us our
unsung hero guests
scientists susan solomon and stephen
anderson who are the recipients of the
future of life award given to people who
you otherwise didn't hear about but
somehow managed to save the freaking
world okay
and so
the the fact that this
award exists is kind of a weird
it's a weird fact right because you
think if someone saved the world they'd
be on the front page of every paper but
what it tells you is that there's
scientists working behind the scenes in
laboratories they're people who are who
are moving agencies and institutions so
that at the end of the day an entire
system has been shifted and
people don't tend to look at the
contents of the sausage they
just eat the sausage exactly sorry to
analogize our two kids and you know what
neil
what you just said it makes so much
sense and this is one of the problems i
have with you three and everyone in your
industry
is that you quietly go about your work
why do you quietly go about your work
so we need we need we have to hire like
pr people just yes
attached to us so so stephen and susan
did this award is it a physical thing or
is it just some distinction
that that they
uh hand you well it is a tremendous
tremendous honor and i i just happen to
have my plaque here
which which oh cool cool so we got a
plaque absolutely extremely heavy and
for those only listening
whoops
yeah for those only listening it's it's
a plaque at least 16 by 20 it looks like
and oh it's gorgeous it's completely
gorgeous
and and you have to if you didn't have a
mantle to put it over you'd have to buy
a house that had a mantle to put it over
because that's where that
i got to find a really strong nail
because this thing is so heavy and it's
very heavy it's got the earth hanging at
the bottom too right
and right under and right underneath the
earth for those of you who are just
listening it says thank you for saving
the world
now chuck how how are your superhero
characters coming along
yeah so uh right now i have uh the real
captain planet and major ecology okay
there you go very nice yeah very nice
yeah we'll go with that
all right so we still this is a cosmic
query so we've only gotten through like
two or three questions let's see if we
can speed up our answers and get a
little more in on this segment so go for
it check okay so this is uh nicholas
lenson who says uh hey there in the book
how to avoid a climate disaster bill
gates proposes that we will only reduce
carbon emissions if we cut the cost of
what he calls green premium on every
human activity uh it sounds like a good
framework do you think reducing the cost
of cleaner alternatives would be enough
to eradicate greenhouse gases and
emissions released by
human activity which of course in the in
the last ipcc it said that uh that we
are indeed the contributing factor here
for finally we got to that well we knew
that that's just okay so stephen let's
direct that to you so if
if we go back to the economic drivers
that motivate people we have green
technol green energy and non-renewable
energy and
it's pretty clear to me that if green
energy ever ended up
physically costing less
than non-renewable energy you could
change the world overnight
so
where are we and where's that headed
the good news is that bill gates is
right that it's a tremendous advantage
that the cost of electricity from wind
and solar has come down
many of you know that right now that
even if you own a relatively recent
coal-fired power plant it's less
expensive to reinvest in solar and wind
than to buy the coal for that power
plant it's especially true if you look
at the downstream effects that you have
to go through cleaning up the coal mines
cleaning up the spoils getting rid of
the combustion byproducts so that's
happening today and it's really just
this dodginess of the infrastructure
that susan mentioned the idea that you
just have to get to work and change this
over and right now you could look at
somewhere case like
new orleans i don't know if you noticed
that the power grid failed during the
floods and one of the huge advantages of
this distributed power from wind and
solar and especially when it's
co-located in the city is you can
maintain electricity for critical
service like medicine and communication
and so forth even when the power grids
down so there's lots of co-benefits
if you look at the big institutions like
the united states military they're
shifting very quickly to solar and wind
and distributed power and they're
electrifying things that people couldn't
imagine have been done in the past so i
think we're i think that's the one of
the brightest spots and bill gates is
absolutely correct that clean energy is
a big part of the solution cool all
right yeah what
what we need is a a good country songs
written about solar and wind
because they got tons of country songs
about coal miners because you've never
heard a country song that said my daddy
was a solar array
like you never heard that very good in
fact i just reminded myself that that
song from the 60s big bad john
right big remember that song
he worked in a coal mine in fact he died
in a coal mine by the end of the song
sorry to give away the the punch line of
that spoiler
but
jimmy dang baked by ed john so you're
right all these like the country songs
of working in the cold my my daddy was a
coal miner my best his daddy was a coal
miner his daddy was a coal miner
so so it would be really funny a whole
suite of songs
my daddy set up solar panels yeah
so yeah all right keep going here we go
um
fred gibson
wants to know this what is the most
what is the most life-changing adaptions
to our lives that will be forced to make
due to our lack of resolve in dealing
with climate change and fred is coming
to us from uh winnipeg manitoba
so this assumes that not all changes
this assumes not all changes will be
smooth and easy and maybe
we will be forced by law or by other
factors susan what do you have well we
get to find out how tasty vegetables
actually can be if you cook them
correctly you know i mean it's not the
mushy peas that my mother used to serve
us out of the can right which we've made
made us all hate vegetables but you know
i'm personally i'm a pescatarian i eat
fish and vegetables and i never had such
delicious vegetables in my life until i
started really thinking about how to
make them tasty and they're easy to make
tasty and i keep thinking they should
redo the popeye
cartoon series where he's looking for
spinach in the produce aisle and
checking it
instead of squirting a can of boiled
spinach into his mouth
so that that's a whole other outlook
right oh man no wonder we all hate them
i mean they you know
stay right here bluto i've got to run
the whole foods
okay popeye
don't be too long
all right
okay all right this is asher osborne and
uh
asher would like to know this i've read
that 70 75 of greenhouse gases are
created by about 100 companies is this
true and can the average individual
really then
make a difference
good question is that you stephen yeah i
think that is
i haven't heard that statistic
but there are gigantic companies in the
world and certainly the 100 biggest
companies would be a big part of the
problem i would just point out that
those 100 companies are buying from
10 000 companies and they're selling to
billions of customers
so if you look at the whole spectrum of
things there's still a lot of room for
everybody to do their part and one of
the things that's happening very quickly
is the companies that have social
responsibility are changing their
product lines they're changing their
procurement
they're deciding that they should
carbon neutralize their total effect so
there's a lot of positive things going
on but it is it is true that there are
some giant companies that are standing
in the way of climate protection and
they certainly
have to be reckoned with and that's as
neil knows that's a classic uh political
problem susan what does it mean to
carbon neutralize
to to go carbon neutral or what does
that mean so it means that uh the the
amount that you generate is equal to the
amount that you take away of carbon
dioxide of carbon dioxide so that way
whatever you do
you're not making the planet worse off
right right so if you're going to for
example go for drive you go for a drive
in your electric vehicle instead of your
fossil fuel powered car and you make
sure that you pay the extra for the wind
source of you know electricity if it
does cost you extra but as we talked
about earlier just make it cheaper and
then you won't have to pay any extra for
it and that's where your energy is going
to come from anyway so if you then if
you are if you still have a fossil fuel
car you trade it in and get one of those
cool new teslas and just go roaring down
the street
okay
okay there you go all right chuck keep
it coming all right this is
helmer van der
uh i think
uh he says
you tried hard on that one i tried man i
tried yeah
i did the best i could
all right um dear honored scientist i am
from the netherlands and i'm pretty
worried about the rising sea levels for
obvious reasons they as they should
what's this your whole country is below
the whole other neither lands means
lowlands i think right
all right
okay he says
but i got to thinking earth could become
uninhabitable in many ways some being
more likely than others in your
professional opinion what is the most
likely cause for earth to become
uninhabitable and it it sounds to me
like this guy spends a lot of time being
depressed
because he's just thinking about
existential threats all over the place
he can't get away from how are we going
out so susan or stephen which of you
thinks about the apocalypse most
you know one of the things one of the
things that the future of life institute
is good for is taking on the hard
problems and so one of the reasons i was
so pleased to win this award is if you
look at the list it's uh nuclear and
biological weapons it's uh
changes in
it inappropriately applied technology of
all kinds and then now it's ozone and
climate so i think there's a whole
spectrum and the way i like to look at
this to remain optimistic is if everyone
did their job
on
ozone depleting substances greenhouse
gases including carbon dioxide the
people that are in charge of
bringing peace to the world and so forth
you need all of that because there's a
lot of mechanisms that could debilitate
the united states and the rest of the
world and nobody would want that so
i think everybody's got to do their job
so chuck so stephen has the complete
list
of what will do us in there that's right
yeah so what are you doing here get back
to work
what are you doing here we need you
get back to your desk
all right all right chuck keep it coming
okay uh this is
cody
klebowski and cody wants to know this
hello all
the main thing i always hear from
climate change deniers
is that humans are not to blame for the
increase in global temperatures can you
please explain
how we can prove
the human responsibility
the countability susan how do you how do
you do that
well uh there's a lot of different ways
i guess the the first thing i would say
is you know the arctic is getting warmer
than the rest of the world
and we expect that it's part just to be
clear you mean it's temperatures rising
faster there's been more warming in the
yard right but it's not it's not
actually warmer than the rest of the
world no i'm sorry it would be bad for
sam i'm sorry okay no no yeah you're
right you're right excuse me i misspoke
yeah so the arctic regions are warming
more
but because of global warming than other
places and if it was coming from the sun
it would be the tropics that would
actually be warming more if it was like
changes in solar activity so that's not
what it is and
um you know it's not because the oceans
and the arctic are giving up heat
especially just there because the oceans
are actually taking up heat everywhere
because they're getting warmer too so
unless you believe that there's magical
other ways to make or destroy energy
which they do which they well yeah some
people do but you know
neil your your listeners are are much
more learned than that not our people
yeah our people
you know yeah you got to have a source
for that energy if the whole planet is
getting hotter and that the source for
that energy is because we put more
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere so so
just to be clear when
when the report a report says
the temperature of the world has
increased by one degree celsius that's
an average
and it is lowest at the equator and and
higher than that at the poles
but people don't think that and then
we're melting you know glacier ice
and so maybe they should just give what
the temperature increases at the polls
that would that could
that might be more alarming to people
than just the global average yeah it's a
good i think uh two and a half times
more yeah and the re the reason is
because the ice retreats and then
there's more heat coming in uh
and and being absorbed so right because
the ice reflects sunlight does the ice
that's right right right right right so
it's a runaway process
chuck we have time for like a half more
question okay great because i saved this
one for last on purpose this is david
peterson hello dr tyson dr solomon dr
anderson when i was a child in the 80s
and 90s i remember the hole in the ozone
layer being a very huge deal the
campaign to ban cfcs seem to have been
very successful in comparison to the
campaign to fight global warming what
lessons can we learn from the ozone
layer campaign and apply them to the
global warming campaign i like it yeah
yeah i'm writing a book that's exactly
about this and i'm going to give it to
you really quick no don't do that buy
the book
there's your answer
go ahead it's okay you get it for free
so uh it's books not ready yet anyhow
it's uh it's it's because
people really cared so you you the
people have to care at least enough to
vote and preferably to go out to your
church or your social club and talk to
other people and get them to care it's
political figures have to get interested
and really want to try to do stuff and
you know barack obama for example really
tried to do stuff there were politicians
who tried to do stuff back then you got
to have industry
playing their role and developing new
technologies which stephen has done so
much to
to promote and make happen and you got
to have good science and you got to have
the economics all work out and it can do
so when all those factors ally with one
another that's what happened and that's
how we solve the ozone problem okay so
to quote chuck
money it's about
[Laughter]
from an earlier yeah i mean so it seems
to me if i were to add to that that if
you really want to change people's
hearts and minds you have to pre-invent
something that they could turn to
so they can take the off ramp and not
feel like they're somehow living a
lesser life that's part of it but but
the the other but back to your veg back
to your vegetable analog yeah you're
right if vegetables are only the side
light to the t-bone steak on your plate
then no one's investing anything in
making those vegetables tasty but as
vegetarians have done and as as vegans
have done if the vegetables become front
and center and more attention is given
and so my wife and i are doing just that
we're celebrating vegetables in ways
that were unthinkable growing up in this
world so i kind of think you need it
there
right so they can say well what am i
going to do you're going to do this oh
my gosh it's cheaper and tastier and
better and then it happens immediately
that's true but you know you know what
else is important is you got to realize
that that steak is actually not good for
you if you have it every night you got
no really you have to understand that
the problem is serious and that you need
to make a change and you know if if this
year isn't convincing lots of people
that it's serious and i don't i i just
don't know what to say to those people
stephen
i would like to say that susan tried
about that list but the part the
montreal protocol was very good at
is that they worked at where the rubber
met the road they identified the
technologies
and promoted them a lot and so if you
compare
the work of the ipcc and the work at the
montreal protocol montreal protocol name
names listed technology gave references
of where you could get it so it was a
much more
publicly oriented system
with a lot less bureaucracy and i think
getting the companies on board with the
customers uh really closes the gap and
the 99 ozone depleting substances
are 100 or so that were now 98
eliminated which is quite a record
well stephen i i'm delighted that you
remain so optimistic
for someone who's as close to the end of
the world as the two of you have been uh
delighted to hear such a positive
outlook uh i think that means hope
springs eternal and and the human spirit
may be what wins out in the end
uh after all we got to call it quits
there uh susan stephen has been a
delight to have you on the show
congratulations for saving the world
when when when when chuck has his
superheroes back we'll invite you to
comment on them to see if they capture
what you did
um
with authenticity
and if they carry the right combination
of superpowers uh so chuck always good
to have you here always a pleasure all
right we're gonna call it quits there
neil degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist as always
[Music]
you